from 52-year age gaps to mature actors
that are constantly paired with super
young starlets some movie kiss scene
simply shouldn't have happened watch at
your own risk
birth is one of those unconventional
movies that pushes the boundaries in all
the wrong ways directed by Jonathan
Glazer the film stars Nicole Kidman as
Anna a widow who believes that a young
boy named Sean played by Cameron Bright
is actually her deceased husband
reincarnated the boy apparently knows
everything about her right down to her
sexual exploits with her husband which
is really all the proof she needs to
dive headfirst into the elaborate
fantasy while other films have explored
the same concept often with humorous
results birth goes the extra mile to
make the content as creepy as possible
by having the 36 year old Kidman smooch
and bathe with her 10 year old co-star
thankfully the scene is meant to be more
unpleasant than arousing but such
moments feel like a creative Mastermind
stretching an obscene premise for the
sake of generating a little controversy
in the end it didn't matter audiences
avoided birth like the plague resulting
in a meager 14 million dollar worldwide
gross while the majority of critics
quickly dismissed the production as
little more than a questionable exercise
in creepiness
As Good As It Gets tells the story of
cantankerous germaphobe Melvin played by
Jack Nicholson who forms an unlikely
friendship with waitress Carroll played
by Helen Hunt written by James L Brooks
The Academy award-winning picture boasts
an abundance of laughs even when it
evolves into a fairly routine love story
however the romance just so happens to
occur between 60 year old Nicholson and
34 year old hunt in fact as good as it
gets leads to a climactic smooch that
feels out of place and more than a
little off-putting considering the
massive age gap between its stars as
Roger Ebert wrote in his review it's
almost painful watching the screenplay
stretch and contort these characters to
fit them somehow into a conventional
formula they're dragged toward the happy
ending screaming and kicking all the way
I'm gonna grab you
Indecent Proposal is one of those fun
erotic dramas of the 90s that generates
as much pathos as it does unintentional
comedy the 1993 hit follows a young
couple played by Demi Moore and Woody
Harrelson everything's fine until
they're approached by a billionaire
played by Robert Redford who offers one
million dollars to spend just one night
with Moore's character
pose
I would offer you one million dollars
directed by Adrian Lynn Indecent
Proposal received scathing reviews upon
its release but still managed to
generate over 266 million dollars in
worldwide ticket sales despite their
26-year age difference Redford and Moore
still managed to generate plenty of heat
on screen at the time Redford was 55
while more was 29 but that didn't stop
them from locking lips obviously the
plot is purposefully constructed to
create maximum awkwardness especially as
a man is essentially paying for a woman
still the discernible age difference
between the two leads is pretty hard to
ignore particularly during the steamier
scenes
Harrison Ford and the late Anne H made
waves when they appeared together in
Ivan reitman's romantic comedy Six Days
Seven Nights in the movie Ford plays a
pilot who gets stranded with an
eccentric magazine editor on a remote
island following a plane crash and much
hilarity ensues the frothy romance is
filled with Adventure and warm-hearted
humor but the audience first has to get
over the idea of seeing a 55 year old
Ford luck lips with a 29 year old H Six
Days Seven Nights was released right
around the time H's relationship with
Ellen DeGeneres made waves throughout
the pop culture landscape only adding to
the controversy Ford ignored the noise
and according to H focused on making a
great romantic comedy instead as H would
remark to Vanity Fair that is why
Harrison Ford is my hero to stand behind
me at such a time when the force of what
I was standing up for could have been
toppled
before she won an Oscar for La La Land
Emma Stone took on a number of more
questionable roles one of those was in
Woody Allen's Magic in the Moonlight
released in 2014 while working with Alan
used to be a badge of honor for any
actor a plethora of his movies feature
female leads who are much much younger
than their male counterparts until she's
very pleasant to look at in this case a
26 year old stone chases after 54 year
old Colin Firth in a plot centered
around Clairvoyance while the pair
displays wonderful chemistry it's not
necessarily believable that Stone's
character would end up with a man twice
her age their big kiss at the finale
feels more forced than necessary mostly
because firth's character seemingly
regards Stone as nothing more than a
friend as a result his sudden change of
heart in the film's third act feels
pretty awkward
as it turns out age discrepancies aren't
just a modern device used to cater to
older actors who think they're still 25
and Billy Wilder's love in the afternoon
which came out in 1957 screen icon Gary
Cooper can be seen kissing Audrey
Hepburn the problem is while Hepburn was
a fairly fresh-faced 28 year old Cooper
was nearly 60 at the time sadly the age
difference wasn't much of a hit with
audiences leading to disappointing box
office receipts and a middling reaction
from critics even Wilder suggested that
the age discrepancy between his two
stars was the reason for the film's poor
performance in the book on Sunset
Boulevard The Life and Times of Billy
Wilder the writer director quipped it
was a flop why because I got cooped the
week he suddenly got old
Liam Neeson was 32 years older than
Olivia Wilde when they appeared together
in Paul haggis's 2013 drama third person
of course even at the ripe old age of 61
Nissan could pass for a reasonably
healthy looking man in his 50s however
as Wilde was just 29 at the time the age
Gap was enough to detract from their
on-screen romance resulting in an
awkward viewing experience critics
didn't take kindly to third person with
only 25 percent awarding the picture a
positive review on Rotten Tomatoes The
two million worldwide box office gross
also proved audiences were likewise
turned off by this tepid effort from the
usually reliable haggis
you know if I don't find a use for you
soon I'm gonna have to get rid of you
Michael Kane turned 50 in 1983 which was
the same year Blame It on Rio was filmed
that didn't stop the critical dud from
casting him to be in a frivolous romance
with a very young Michelle Johnson who
was 17 when the dark comedy was filmed
the pair spends much of the film's run
time flirting kissing and having sex to
an uncomfortable degree as Roger Ebert
declared in his review Blame It on Rio
has the mind of a 1940s Bongo comedy and
the Heart of a porno film it's really
unsettling to see how casually this
movie takes a serious situation indeed
director Stanley Donan uses his absurd
premise to deliver cheap laughs which is
probably why no one has spoken of this
movie since its release I really
appreciate you not saying anything
Adrian Lynn the director behind erotic
Thrillers nine and a half weeks and
indecent proposals strikes again with
1997's Lolita based on the book of the
same name by Vladimir Nabokov Lolita
explores the sexual relationship between
a middle-aged man played by Jeremy Irons
and a 14 year old girl portrayed by
Dominique Swain in the controversial
film iron's relationship with Swain
doesn't leave much to the imagination as
Swain was only 15 at the time body
doubles were needed for explicit sex
scenes and moments involving nudity
while cushions were reportedly placed
between the actors during sequences that
required bodily contact it's a
disturbing watch to say the least
Jack Nicholson has enjoyed a number of
leading roles alongside much younger
women and that includes in the romantic
comedy Something's Gotta Give in the
latter Nicholson portrays a man named
Harry who sleeps with women half his age
as a means of retaining his youth ladies
Sensational meeting you Harry eventually
abandons his ways in favor of the more
age-appropriate Erica played by Diane
Keaton but before that happens audiences
are subjected to his fleeting romance
with a 31 year old Amanda Pete making
her 35 years younger than Nicholson at
the time
Bill Murray and Scarlett Johansson light
up the screen and Sophia Coppola's Lost
in Translation brilliantly acted and
wonderfully directed the film was a hit
with audiences and critics when it was
released in 2003. however some viewers
were a little creeped out by the finale
in which a 52 year old Murray plans a
kiss on 17 year old Johansen discussing
the age difference Coppola told The
Daily Beast there were certain actors
that people mentioned for the bill part
and if they were lying in bed that could
have been creepy but it's just something
about how Bill is that it never came off
lecherous maybe because he's such a kid
Sean Connery aged incredibly well which
allowed him to play the lead in a number
of action films well into his late 60s
however such genre entries usually
require a young Leading Lady to Star
alongside the film's hero and Hollywood
was more than happy to oblige in the
case of 1999's entrapment the 68 year
old actor teamed up with a 29 year old
Catherine Zeta-Jones resulting in an
awkward romance that was borderline
ludicrous
I was prepared for everything
except you the film also has connory's
60 year old Robert Mac McDougall scaling
high-rises and breaking into vaults
actions that require audiences to bury
their skepticism under about 50 tons of
popcorn yet seeing the former James Bond
engage in Passionate on-screen love
making with Zeta Jones's eager to please
young Thief is simply one ridiculous
plot Point too many sure the Duo's
on-screen chemistry can't be denied but
a casting director somewhere is in dire
need of a reality check
Drew Barrymore was only 17 when she
swapped Spit with a 58 year old Tom
Skerritt in the 1992 erotic Thriller
Poison Ivy the story centers around a
young psychopath named Ivy who seduces
the much older father of her best friend
in order to become a part of their
family sure Ivy Resorts too murder to
complete her Wicked plan but you can't
make an omelet without breaking some
eggs right inevitably scare its
character is seduced by his daughter's
friend and they end up having sex on the
hood of his car in the middle of a
rainstorm context aside seeing a
teenager make out with a nearly 60 year
old man doesn't exactly push the thrill
buttons while the scene is intended to
make viewers uncomfortable that doesn't
change the fact that Barrymore and
scaret Dove head first into murky
territory for the sake of fleeting
superficial entertainment the 1971 dark
comedy Herald and mod has endured over
the years as a cult classic thanks to
its big heart and deep Explorations
about life and death the film tells the
tale of Harold played by Bud Court a
depressed 20 year old who spends his
days attending funerals and looking for
unique ways to kill himself by chance he
meets Maud played by Ruth Gordon an
eccentric free-spirited older woman
prone to uprooting trees from the city
and returning them to the forest The Odd
Couple form a unique Union powerful
enough to propel them through the
doldrums of life however that Union
eventually crosses into the bazaar when
Harold and mod begin Romancing one
another while it's plausible that a
young man might befriend a much older
woman seeing a 20 year old boy kiss a
woman who is 52 years a senior is not
quite the happily ever after audiences
we're expecting
foreign
[Music]